कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
सीखने वाले हैं बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग वर्क
लार्सन अब यह जो वर्ड है ना यह डे टुडे
लाइफ में या फिर जब बोलते हैं तो बहुत
बाहर और बहुत अच्छी तरीके के लिए यूज होता
है तो इसीलिए यहां आज उसके कुछ इंपोर्टेंट
यूजर्स सीखने वाले हैं तो सबसे पहले हम यह
चलता के से देखते हैं कि वह चलता बहुत
सिंपल है आपको भी स्क्रीन पर दिख रहा होगा
इस प्लास्टर दो ग्लास एंट्री लैच वीर
विल्सन एकदम सिंपल चलना सब को समझ में आया
कि वह इस्लाम से दूर ले अगर हम इसको यूज
ना वह बहुत ही सीखते हैं तो सबसे पहले
इसको यूज ना उसमें से ढाल की तरह से चलेगा
मेन वर्ग में में रहेगा तो इसका यूज करते
हैं अरे यार करवा लेंगे फिर करवाते हैं
कि कोई चीज आ करते हो और दूसरे से करवा
लेते हो फॉर एग्जांपल मैं अपनी गाड़ी
रिपेयर करता हूं इस रिफ़िल रॉ मानव टो पर
अगर मैं किसी से वह किसी मैकेनिक सिर्फ
करवा लेता हूं तो मैं क्या बोलूंगा इस्लाम
स मानव टो रिपेयर रन ओके वहीं मैं अपना
शर्ट धोता हूं इस वर्ष चमाइन है अमरुद मैं
अपना शर्ट किसी से बुलवा लेता हूं इस लाख
सफेद मर्डर वाचन सिंपल एडमिट करवा लेना
अगर वह तो क्या करोगे लाख सितम को मॉडल
नरगिस करोगे मेंबर एंड चाहिए अब इसका जो
दूसरा व का यूज है ना वह बहुत बार आपको
अगर जर्मनी में हो तो दिखेगा कि क्लच को
लड्डू जवाब बोलते हो लेट के इससे तो व
होता है लखन के हैं लाभ के हैं या फिर लंच
पीठ पीछे लाइसेंस फिजिशियन और फिर लहसुन
स्टेटस रिंगटोन
ए सिंपल है तो यह लूट की तरह बहुत बार
मजबूत है उसका और एक यूज है इससे लोग
कंफ्यूज होते हैं लैंड आफ छोड़ दो यार
लिमिट की तरह लास्ट रेमेडीस 10 छोड़ दो
यार उसे लाख संगीता या फिर वह सिगरेट नहीं
छोड़ सकता है अरकान दास रावण निष्ठ लक्षण
चित्रकूट स्मोकिंग कैन दास रावण लिस्ट
लहसुन इसमें नार्मल व की तरह अब इसको
थोड़ा आगे जाकर थोड़ा कि लक्ष्मी लोग मतलब
छोड़ दो फिर अल्लाह लीव मे अलोन फिर मशरूम
फिर लोग शांति से रहने दो यह जो सारे है
यह और यूज हो गया तो यह में और उसके कुछ
टाइप्स
है तो इसे लाइक और मैं आपको जस्ट बाद बोल
देता हूं कि अल्लाह करना इस तरीके से भी
मैं मेरी बेटी को संडे को टीवी देखने देता
हूं ओके आई लव आईलैंड हर वॉच टीवी ऑन संडे
तो क्या का या इस्लाम स मािनत डॉक्टर आम
जोनटाग पेरेंट्स दहन अलर्ट्स पर यह सारे
न्यूज़ चैनल वह जो नेटिव्स है जो निकली
अपनी वह मातृभाषा उनको करने तो हमारी यह
चार इंपोर्टेंट कौन से थे सबसे पहला करवा
लेते हैं इस लक्ष्य मानव टो त्रिपुरारी
शरण दूसरा कि वह चलो करते हैं पसंद किए
हैं तीसरा लिक्विड लहसुन जीता और चौथा
जनरल ऐडमिशन रूल मुझे आशा है कि आप सबको
यह कंफर्म समझ में आई होगी हम मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में धन्यवाद